we're joined by cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus
um doctor so so new york is opening
la and chicago all remote learning
other districts still making decisions
is it still just wait and see for a lot
of these states and cities
hopefully it's data driven i mean
looking at the rate of cases and the
trajectory of those cases in an
individual region to make the decision
you know there's no right decision here
kids need to learn they need to
socialize at the same time
we need to obviously stop this virus so
the notion of
opening a school with no protection that
is no mass and no social distancing
makes no sense
opening a school with behavior changes
is possible
if there's not ramping cases and that's
what we're seeing around the country
new york is doing it right now and
they've said that if the number goes
above five percent in
any region that region will close their
schools
dr aegis what makes this so difficult to
track is that you have a number of
people that are spreading this virus and
they don't even have symptoms of it
can you talk about the new research
that's come out regarding people that
are asymptomatic
you know we've always talked about that
there can be asymptomatic spread but the
first study
to actually demonstrate how this happens
came out this week
and it was data from south korea and
what they showed is that
individuals who are symptomatic or
asymptomatic had the same amount of
virus
in the nose the throat and the lungs
the same amount of virus and so we can
assume from that there's the same amount
of spread between an asymptomatic
or asymptomatic person and so obviously
that's why this virus has taken off in
the country people not knowingly
leave the house and can spread this
virus but the same amount of virus and
symptomatic asymptomatic was a little
surprising to me
but those are the data dr um on the
vaccine
front right now realize this won't
necessarily solve everything as we've
been warned but different
different drugs or different vaccines
are in different phases of development
right now what are we learning about
that
so there are really three big vaccine
programs
in phase three studies that we are
producing here in america the
astrazeneca oxford vaccine
is in phase three started actually
several months ago south africa brazil
in the united kingdom
looking very encouraging and we should
know that data hopefully sometime in
september
we have the modernist study which
started two weeks ago and we have the
pfizer study
which also started recently those three
studies are really our hope in the short
run that we get data
that the data show that this can reduce
dramatically symptoms in the virus
and that we can get this vaccine out to
people people are worried about will the
vaccine be politicized
the answer is no i mean it's data driven
we know the criteria the vaccine has to
reach
if it reaches those criteria we will
have a vaccine in the fall
if it doesn't we won't all right dr
david agus i know you said the key too
is a vaccine that works
thank you so much